next question is from Lisa Lisa says how
can you tell that you're in a bad
neighborhood okay this is this is a good
question
I assume that by bad Lisa should we
should we believe that Lisa means an
unsafe neighborhood is that yeah high
crime rate so it's a high crime rate
okay I think there's a few different
signs it depends what we're talking
about certainly if you see bars on
windows that can suggest it's a bad
neighborhood but at the same time in my
old neighborhood in Brooklyn I was very
close to the neighborhood called
Brooklyn Heights one of the most
expensive neighborhoods in the world
never mind the United States and first
floor apartments still had bars on the
windows so what might seem like a pretty
reliable method of figuring out whether
there you're in a bad neighborhood
it doesn't always apply dollar stores
payday loan places title loan places
pawn shops those can be signs that you
might be in a a CD or neighborhood and
again I'm trying to be careful to be
what is a bad neighborhood I don't I
think it's important not not to sort of
be unfairly characterizing neighborhoods
in a certain way what some some people
say when you see a lot of bail bonds
place you know you're in a bad
neighborhood again the neighborhood I
lived in in Brooklyn was not a cheap
neighborhood and we had several bail
bonds places because we were near the
courts and so I don't know that that's
reliable either Pat right I would point
to things like maybe the houses are
dilapidated or you know there's just not
a lot going around during the daytime or
you maybe see you feeding on the walls
four feet in yellow and again I'm going
to be visiting my family in Buenos Aires
Argentina next month
just about all of the city is covered in
graffiti it's basically if you took
Paris and let it become dilapidated for
a couple decades and added graffiti
Paris plus waiting 20 years plus
graffiti is when our site is and that
includes some pretty safe and nice
neighborhoods as well so it just depends
on where you are and this by the way is
why sometimes tourists to other
countries get themselves into bed
situations which is you get used to
whatever the the signs are in your
immediate area about good versus bad
neighborhoods and whatever that means
you get used to that paradigm and you
might go somewhere that is very very
different and you might incorrectly
believe that you're in an unsafe
neighborhood when you're in a very safe
neighborhood I mean Brooklyn is a really
good example of that many many of the
neighborhoods in Brooklyn you might also
be in the opposite situation where you
believe you're in a very safe place
because it looks a certain way that you
don't associate with being a bad
neighborhood and it turns out that it's
a particularly high crime neighborhood
for example that's how it is here in
Boston I mean even our studio is in an
office building that seems like it's the
first area to be gentrified in the whole
community sure but you walk 10 minutes
down the road and you're in a decently
bad neighborhood and you have to watch
yourself out there so it can be pretty
deceptive even just going block to block
around here yeah I mean Boston is sort
of known for that being a relatively
small city geographically there's some
statistic about how I think you can
travel some very short amount of
distance and have something like a 15
year difference in life expectancy due
to crime rates and access to health care
and and financial discrepancies etc so
there and there are some ideas if
there's any I'm missing email and leave
them in the youtube comments whatever is
good for you